well my friends inflation is down
significantly and Joe Biden's approval
rating continues to climb in a horrible
turn of events for the right which wants
to continue to tell the lie that
democratic presidents are terrible for
the economy now you all know that I
don't actually play these games when it
comes to the economy you all know that
when we talk like this it's sort of
tongue-in-cheek because the reality is
that on many of these issues presidents
have very little influence one way or
the other I don't play the gas prices
game I will jokingly say how did Joe
Biden get gas prices to be down a dollar
seventy per gallon as they are
but of course I don't really give them
credit for that the same way that I
don't blame him for the fact that gas
prices went up but for the right Wingers
that see the world in this way we should
be aware of what is going on and as I'm
I'm an idiot when it comes to this stuff
but I predicted we would get down into
the sixes in the first part of 2023 and
inflation would probably be down into
the four fives by the middle or third
quarter of 2023 and we continue to go in
that direction no we learned this
morning CNBC report consumer prices fell
0.1 percent in December in line with
expectations
excluding food and energy core CPI row
0.3 percent on an annual basis headline
CPI meaning Top Line inflation is now up
6.5 percent while core inflation is up
5.7 percent the biggest reason for the
easing in inflation came from a sharp
drop in gasoline clean prices which are
now lower on a year-over-year basis I
want to tell everybody again because
people are so confused and they write to
me things that make no sense when we
talk about 6.5 percent
what we're talking about is over the
last year so we just got the December
number so when we now say year over year
we're talking about price increase from
December 2021 to December 2022. every
month you shift by one month what is the
12-month period we're talking about so
in December when we got the November
number we were talking about inflation
from November 21 to November 22.
it's now January we've now added the
December 22 inflation data and removed
the November 21 so we've changed the
range instead of November 21 to November
22 we're now talking about December 21
to December 22. that inflation number is
down from being in the eights to 6.5
percent that is what we are talking
about when we talk about inflation this
is now six months in a row that
inflation has come down
core inflation from October to December
was only 3.1 percent annualized that's
the lowest such reading in 15 months gas
as I mentioned is down a dollar seventy
per gallon from its peak food inflation
is slowing last month we saw actually
the smallest increase in food prices in
almost two years the cost of goods is
falling for electronics used car prices
have come down which got completely out
of control wages are higher now than six
months ago so it's not prices are coming
down and so are wages wages are still
higher prices are lower when you adjust
everything for inflation we have the
lowest unemployment rate in 50 years and
it is at least partially being perceived
by voters
as Joe Biden being a generally good
Steward of the economy you don't have to
believe as I don't believe that every
one of these numbers is related to who's
President I didn't believe it under
Trump and I don't believe it's the case
under Biden I'm not playing games with
that but when you see the zoomed out
version of what's happening in the
country you see a pretty steady uptrend
in Joe Biden's approval which bottomed
out in Late July
and as you if you're looking on the
screen it's been up up up and there's a
new little uptick here even in the last
week where Joe Biden's approval is now
up to 44 now you might say 44 that's
terrible
um yeah I mean listen the the point here
is
in the modern
hyper polarized climate of American
politics you look at Bush Obama and
Trump approvals over time
44 at this point in one's term is
actually just fine it's uncontroversial
is the point the idea that the country
is furious and disgusted with Joe Biden
it's just not borne out in the data so
skip the David you're a democratic chill
stuff I've never been a registered
Democrat I don't care about Joe Biden I
don't care about the Democratic party
what I'm coming to you and saying is the
American people are realizing that what
Republicans are offering is nonsense if
you look at the Republican priorities
that have been made clear
since they took over the House of
Representatives very recently their
ideas benefit the super wealthy they
want to
essentially help the wealthy avoid taxes
at the expense of ordinary middle class
taxpayers House Republicans introduced a
bill to block actions that would lower
gas prices they gutted a bunch of Ethics
requirements they are pushing a bill
that would actually increase tax rates
on middle class families at the net
effective level and they're open to open
to cuts to Social Security and Medicare
that's what Republicans are offering now
hopefully they won't get any of it done
because the Republicans don't control
the Senate but inflation numbers
improving very good economic numbers you
see what Republicans are offering it
makes sense that Joe Biden's approval
keeps ticking up and quite frankly
18 months ago yeah 12 months ago roughly
um I would not have said Joe Biden is
well positioned for re-election in 2024.
right now I think Joe Biden is
dramatically better positioned for
re-election doesn't mean he is running
or should run or shouldn't run but just
based on the data the economy is quite
strong and that tends to um bode well
when presidents argue for their own
re-election they are continuing by the
way on the Republican side to be
complete lunatics when it comes to
abortion the latest is the the Attorney
General of Alabama says women can be
prosecuted for taking abortion pills a
report from al.com
one week after the federal government
made it easier to get abortion pills
Alabama attorney general Steve Marshall
said Tuesday women in Alabama who use
those pills to end pregnancies could be
prosecuted that's despite wording writes
al.com in Alabama's new human life
protection act that criminalizes
abortion providers and prevents its use
against the people receiving abortions
instead the Attorney General's office
said Alabama could rely on an older lab
an older law designed to protect
children from meth lab fumes
quote the human life protection act
targets abortion providers exempting
women upon whom an abortion is performed
or attempted to be performed it does not
provide an across-the-board exemption
from all criminal laws including the
chemical endangerment law that's what
they would use to prosecute a woman who
ingests an abortion pill to end a
pregnancy the chemical endangerment law
this is a terrible idea and remember
that Donald Trump thought of this before
Donald Trump understood you're not
supposed to say we go after the women
Donald Trump had this incredible moment
when being interviewed by Chris Matthews
back in this was 2015 or 2016 where he
said yeah you should punish the women
remember this do you believe in
punishment for abortion yes or no as a
principle the answer is that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form 10 things 10 years now the next day
Donald Trump backed back that he he
walked that back he was told immediately
Donald you're off script we say punish
the doctors we don't punish the women
but this is something that Republicans
have toyed around with for a long time
now when you criminalize abortion you
restrict access to safe and legal
abortion you don't actually limit
abortion and you directly attack the
autonomy and sovereignty that women
should have over their own bodies they
talk about freedom
Liberty Etc except not in this
particular case women should have the
right to make decisions about their
bodies and their own health care the
government shouldn't be able to force
them to carry pregnancies to term
against their will and the idea of
criminally Prosecuting a woman who makes
the decision to take an abortion pill is
really Gilead type stuff Prosecuting
women who takes a who take abortion
pills also puts their health and
well-being at risk because again when
you dissuade women from legal and safe
Medical Services they pursue sometimes
illegal and often unsafe services and by
the way if you care about this which a
lot of them don't these types of laws
always disproportionately affect poor
women
and women of color because I mean listen
you look at in Argentina for example
where abortion was illegal for a long
time you think wealthy women weren't
having safe abortions they were uh but
of course they needed to have the money
for it and this is often the way that
that it goes there seems to be one
Republican who gets that this type of
thing is a bad idea and that's Nancy
mace Nancy mace uh Republican
congresswoman appeared on Morning Joe
when was this uh oh this morning I
believe it was and she said
um it's not really a great thing for
Republicans to be pushing this type of
stuff now just this week the Anthony
believes the governor of Alabama said
that women should be thrown in prison if
they take an abortion pill so I mean
Plan B is something that 90 of America
supports women shouldn't be thrown in
prison neither should doctors at this
juncture either but one of the things
that I've been harping on this week and
for months now is that if we're gonna
get serious about saving lives right if
we were serious about that issue we have
to have legislation that will pass a
democrat-controlled senate and a
republican-controlled house one of the
things that we could do right now is
giving women access to birth control if
you want to get serious about saving now
she is saying all the right things but
the truth is she voted for a lot of this
stuff anyway so she is apparently
recognizing at least for PR purposes
that Republicans should look in a
different direction but when you look at
her voting record it really leaves
something to be desired at the end of
the day this is not something the
American people are increasingly going
for and Republicans need to figure out
where do we draw the line in order to
avoid damaging ourselves as they argue
with arguably did to some degree in the
midterms but that's the new one
Alabama's saying we could prosecute
women who take abortion pills we're
going to take a very quick break make
sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
channel at youtube.com the davidpackman
show plenty more coming up today
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the pressure is hilariously building on
lying Republican Congressman George
Santos or Anthony De volder or whatever
his name is to resign yesterday there
was an event held by the Nassau County
Republicans and a bunch of other
officials and it is just delightful and
I am increasingly hopeful that they are
going to force this guy out and you know
that they love to say oh they're trying
to destroy his career
he lied about everything he deserves to
have his career destroyed sometimes it's
right for you to lose your job folks
here is Nassau County Republican Jared
Joseph Cairo saying that George Santos
should resign immediately the reason
this is the district he represents
that's why we're talking about Nassau
County the County Republican committee
nor should he serve in public service
nor is an elected official he's not
welcome here at Republican headquarters
for meetings or at any of our events as
I said he's disgraced the House of
Representatives and we do not consider
him one of our Congress people
today on behalf of the Nassau County
Republican committee I am calling for
his immediate resignation now this is
all great and I love it and we'll get
George Santos's reaction momentarily
increasingly it seems as though Nassau
County Republicans knew that this guy
was lying about a bunch of this stuff
it's not been definitively proven but
it's increasingly looking that way so
really what they're they're having a
problem with is that this makes them
look bad I don't know that they actually
care about George Santos lying about
everything it's that now everyone knows
George Santos lied about everything and
it makes them look really bad it's still
very funny here is
um a claim that George Santos claimed he
was a volleyball star at Baroque College
which he didn't actually graduate from
and that he had a champ a volleyball
championship look at this
explain what was on that resume well to
my recollection it said he went to
Baruch College said he went to NYU he
later or perhaps at the interview I
didn't attended uh that he sought a
master's degree said that he worked in
finance I don't recall was it city city
group I think uh said he was very
successful told me personally that that
he had made a lot of money at that age
and was successful in life
we got into it started getting personal
about the fact that he came from a poor
background but that he was able to be
very successful told me I remember
specifically I'm into sports a little
bit that he was a star on the Baroque
volleyball team and that they won the
league championship
what can I tell you it is a joke but
also the joke is these Republicans who
it seemed like they had these suspicions
for a long time and now all of a sudden
they're like well the guy should resign
I actually remember when um George
Santos uh developed an incredible
surgical technique back in the 1930s and
it was a real real big advancement in
medicine as you can imagine next we
heard from Republican Congressman Brian
Fitzpatrick now this is Meaningful
because this is Fitzpatrick who is a
sitting member of Congress saying he
shouldn't be here and you know Kevin
McCarthy has resisted saying this type
of thing
um Fitzpatrick says he simply should not
be here to happen before the house
leadership
you're you know part of that
joins the calls for Santa's to resign
yeah thanks for having me Andrea I don't
think he should be here that's for sure
but there's a process in place that has
to apply equally to all members from
both parties in both Chambers and that's
a house uh Ethics Committee as your
panel just pointed out to the extent
that there's concerns about how long
that would take we should just have an
expedited review there's got to be a
system in place that's consistently
applied across the board all right so
anyway kind of playing a both sides sort
of thing but he is saying George Santos
shouldn't be here then we heard from
Hempstead Town supervisor Donald Clavin
who says that the guy is a joke and he's
making them a joke and it is true they
were already a joke though that's the
thing he's just George Santos is making
them more of a joke you see a unified
voice here now what he's unified the
country in their opposition to him he's
a national joke he's an international
joke true but this joke's got to go
right and it's on us calling him for to
resign immediately not tomorrow not next
week today all right so George Santos
confronted at the House of
Representatives Yesterday by Rachel
Scott but will you resign he says that
he will not take a look at this guys
the New York Republicans are calling you
a disgrace you will not resign
all right so off goes Congressman Santos
de valder whatever his name is I really
hope they push this guy out this
everything else aside Republican
complicity in this they knew when did
they know all this different that
Republicans are dishonest I hope this
guy gets pushed out and I hope it
happens soon let's talk about a couple
other George Santos lies it now appears
as though George Santos slash Anthony
devolder may have uh lied about his Cova
diagnosis everything has to be
hyperbolic with Santos and he once
claimed to be one of the first people in
the United States to be diagnosed with
covid-19 uh which is like what this is
the Hallmark of pathological Liars where
they lie about things no one really
cares about like
someone had to be one of the first
people diagnosed with covet does it
really matter who it was but he had to
claim he was one of those people a
Business Insider reports George Santos
claimed to be one of the first people in
the U.S diagnosed with covet that looks
to be bogus too
George Santos's latest dubious claim
involves a Cova diagnosis from 2020. the
timeline of testing positive and getting
sick differs in various retellings of
the story his descriptions of the
severity of his illness have also
changed over time
the first case of covet in New York was
confirmed on March 1st 2020. and Santo
said in a conservative podcast he had
symptoms of covid just a week later
around March 8th 9th unfortunately on
the 9th of March I became symptomatic
with what we all know very well covet
AKA coronavirus commonly known as the
Chinese flu on the 11th I ended up in
the hospital really bad fever body aches
he said he was in a hospital in Queens
he was there by ambulance spent five
hours in isolation had fever he was
hallucinating and ultimately tested
positive on March 14th and subsequently
negative on March 26th but when he later
talked about the story he had a
different story both in terms of the
severity and the timeline on the day
Santos says he got a positive test he
was bedridden with a fever his campaign
put out a press release including a
quote for him from him and didn't
mention that he was sick it's kind of
weird to put out a statement about covid
on a day on which you're positive and
you're so sick you can't leave your bed
and you don't mention you have it four
days later he was on Fox Business and he
seemed completely fine
very weird and meanwhile in a September
2020 interview with the Long Island
Outlet the island now he says the
hospital said oh just take some Advil or
Aleve
and March 5th 2021 he said on Twitter it
was his anniversary of going to the
hospital for covid but that lines up
with a completely different date
so he lied about his employment history
he lied about his educational history he
lied about his athletic Acumen he lied
about being Jewish from a family of
Holocaust Survivors it appears as though
he also lied about the covid-19 timeline
really wacky and bizarre stuff I hope
they do destroy his career because he
deserves to have it destroyed now I'm
not saying he shouldn't work and he
should starve okay he should have his
career in the position that he obtained
based on lying about everything
destroyed that career he can go back and
you know if he thinks that he's a
finance guy even though those were lies
go go back and work and finance or you
know get some job somewhere else but the
job he got on the basis of the lies he
should lose and let's hope that that
happens one last George Santos slash
Anthony divulder story George Santos is
now uh the target of three ethics
complaints over his campaign spending
his campaign fundraising and his
financial disclosure Business Insider
and Brian Metzger have a piece about
this the left-leaning advocacy group and
citizens united is going to be filing
three ethics complaints against George
Santos alleging campaign Finance
violations and adding to a number of
other complaints
um the group's complaint with the
Department of Justice argues Santos
violated the Ethics in Government Act
but not by not only filing a required
Financial disclosure almost a year late
but also most likely making several
omissions related to assets he's
purported to hold the complaint with the
office of congressional ethics argues
that he violated federal law by
soliciting campaign contributions in
exchange for attending a swearing-in
event on Capitol grounds last month his
team advertised round-trip bus tickets
from New York to DC a lunch and
attendance at Santos is swearing in and
a tour of the capital if you donate at
least 100 bucks federal law prevents the
use of official resources in connection
with campaign activity huh that's
disappointing isn't it the group's
complaint with the FEC focuses on a
purported seven hundred thousand dollar
personal loan that he made to his Camp
campaign that the group says either came
from a shell company or was a prohibited
corporate contribution
uh you can read about the details of
each of each of these complaints this is
you know this is a very important guy at
the end of the day George Santos is the
first person to ever walk across the
Pacific Ocean he can turn Mountain Dew
into liquid silver and obviously I'm
kidding and this is a very very bad
start for George Santos it is
increasingly clear that the Republican
party is panicking but only because it
looks bad they don't actually care about
this guy being a liar McCarthy has still
not even made any criticisms it appears
as though there's some kind of you know
I'm not saying it's a illegal bribery
but just a sort of quid pro quo Santos
pledged to support McCarthy for speaker
and McCarthy may be pledged not to
suggest that Santos should resign that
at least seems to be holding true for
the time being we'll see if it changes
but Republicans only care about this
insofar as it's damaging their
credibility I hope Santos resigns let's
hope by Monday he's gone all of of these
clips will be on our Instagram which you
can find by searching Instagram for
David packman show
you value what we do at the Pacman show
remember to support us on patreon go to
patreon.com davidpackman show where you
can get access to behind the scenes
videos The Daily bonus show the
commercial free Daily Show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to welcome back to the program today
Steve Almond who's the author of The New
York Times bestsellers candy freak and
against football the new novel is called
all the secrets of the world and you can
find him on Twitter at Steve Almond Joy
uh Steve great to have you back on today
yeah good to be with you David so we
reviewed in the aftermath of this
horrible incident that took place on the
NFL field with Demar Hamlin your
appearance with Fox News host Laura
Ingram where you point pointed out some
of the things she has previously said on
her program which she didn't
particularly like and you there was so
much that took place in that interview
and I know many in our audience really
appreciated it so let's just start at
something very very top level what
happened with Demar Hamlin was very
visible in the sense that it happened at
a very particular moment in a game he
suffered a cardiac arrest during a game
and that makes it a much more
interesting media story because it has a
sort of beginning a middle and
presumably some end where he's now been
released from the hospital and so on and
so forth the the truth is and you've
been writing about how there's a much
slower motion story that afflicts many
other players that doesn't lend itself
to this beginning middle end of hey it
happened during the game which is the
brain injury and the cumulative effect
of football talk a little bit about how
the media reaction is so dramatically
different to what took place on the
field over a week ago versus that bigger
story
yeah it's kind of crazy like you saw in
the appearance with Ingram I basically
said hey you know there is there are
these big media events that you know the
reason I'm even snuck onto your fascist
network is because you know somebody
let's find a libtard who hates football
it's that kind of uh zero-sum thinking
propagandist thinking yeah and I try to
sort of calmly say to her you know the
NFL's own actuaries did admit that 30 of
their players are going to wind up with
brain damage because of the accretion of
these sub-concussive events invisible
inside the helmet thousands of them
absorbed over a career and literally
they cause brain damage in this major
American workplace and you sort of said
it before her like what if 30 percent of
Fox News were getting brain damage I
think actually they're giving brain
damage right what if by by Design but I
think what if this was in another
American workplace and just try to set
out for her the the Monstrous double
standard that applies when when it comes
to football that there's this workplace
where literally a third of the employees
are going to get and it's just crickets
it's like no reaction to that at all and
it's because and I think that's actually
writ large the media's general reaction
it's a complicated story it's a story
that's happening out of view and in fact
the NFL paying off that lawsuit
settling it is precisely what the NFL
wanted to happen their nightmare is
junior seau's family or Michael Webb
Mike Webster's family or any of these
guys even Tony Dorsett
um you know famous players and their
families talking about what it's like to
live with CTE they just want none of
that in the public eye and their content
I think in a sense with the Demar Hamlin
time you know story because that is as
you point out that's going to be very
satisfying he's getting better the
medical you know he was he recovered and
God thank God he's getting better but
let's step back and say literally for
every Demar Hamlin there is another
player who is in his 40s or 50s or 60s
who doesn't know where he is who doesn't
recognize his family anymore who
suffered permanent cognitive decline in
brain damage and that's happening out of
you and I think that's kind of the deal
that Americans make if I can't see it
really in a sense what's fascinating to
me David we're a lot of businesses are
in the empty empathy suppression
business and that's what the NFL is in
it's in the empathy suppression and
their players have to suppress their
empathy but also by implication the fans
also have to suppress their empathy they
have to really occlude their moral
imagination so that they cannot imagine
that scenario and that's how I think we
continue to be able to consume stuff
that's really destructive whether it's a
football game or a hamburger whatever it
is we ignore the slaughterhouse and we
like take a big bite of the bacon
cheeseburger that's kind of the big deal
of American capitalism and when you try
to connect those dots and say I know you
can't see it I know that in your fragile
mindset we're hiding from you all the
child labor that makes our miraculous
devices I think most Americans myself
included to it a large extent agree to
that it's a kind of complicity because
we don't want to look at the underside
of these complicated moral undertakings
it's too complicated it's too nuanced
and it's too psychologically and
emotionally inconvenient and with you
know I think you can you can find in
other sports not exactly analogous
circumstances but moral questions that
come up maybe we can say I mean you know
with the World Cup in Qatar for a decade
I talked about
corruption was how it even ended up in
Qatar slave labor and death in terms of
the building of the stadiums
um uh claims that there's going to be
kosher food but then they say then all
of a sudden there's no Kosher food and
it's based on you know the religious
perspective all these different things
and then at the end of the day I'm from
Argentina and every four years I want to
see if maybe we're going to get a win
and we finally got it and I watched the
games right I at the end of the day I
watch the games am I making
a moral trade there in some sense I mean
I guess I kind of am but it feels like
it's a different one than with football
because it's well I don't know I mean
what's different about the Qatar World
Cup thing and then saying football's bad
for the players brains but I really
enjoy it I'm gonna watch it anyway well
I think they're the same it's the same
cognitive dissonance that and I guess
what I tried to do and against football
was not say football's dumb and brutal
and you shouldn't you know consume it
because it's misogynistic and you know
systemically racist and I didn't you
know I think those things happen to be
true and it's also a remarkable
spectacle and it's also you know what's
happening in the culture and therefore a
way to feel connected to it or you have
a personal connection to your team
um and those two things have to live
side by side and what I think the media
tries to do is sort of partition them
out and say well it's time for your five
minutes of moral contemplation in
anguish and now it's time for your three
hours of game right and I think it's
very uncomfortable when people have to
live with uh it's sort of negative
capability the two opposing thoughts
have to be held in the mind and heart at
the same time but that's like what
adults are doing all the time if they're
living you know sort of awake in some
way and I think it's partly what fox and
other propaganda Outlets are in the
business of trying to suppress they want
everything to be either or it's never
both and and so you know when I come on
the Ingram show the Chiron which I
couldn't see of course because I'm
sitting in a little van just staring at
a black dot with Laura Ingram
interrupting me in my ear but what I
what I see later on is there um they're
trying to turn you off to football
that's what the Chiron reads and it's
just this classic how can we make you
afraid who's trying to you know how can
we exalt your grievance so that you can
hide from your own vulnerabilities we
will help you with that and what to me
is really sad is is the sense that there
isn't an opportunity like I go on the
Ingram show and I realize we're not
going to have a serious discussion at a
certain point I go okay I'm going to
take my shots here because you're not
going to actually be in a good faith
dialogue with me about how complicated
football is that it can be beautiful and
bonding and blah blah blah and and
narratively very satisfying and at the
same time that it's got a set of values
and practices that are just inherently
corrupt and that is not ever going to be
the discussion that I can have with with
her so I just we just get into a brawl
which is really just sort of feeding the
entertainment industry that she's in but
there does exist a world or they're used
to in media where that was really
literally the rule of the fairness
Doctrine said you cannot have a single
outlet that just puts out one idea or
philosophy or set of propaganda you have
to have the essence of free speech is
um sort of different shades of opinion
reasonable opinion coming up against one
another that's what you that's the
reason I Lament The Death of the
fairness Doctrine because it created the
opportunity for somebody like Laura
Ingram or Tucker Carlson or any of these
propagandists to be challenged in real
time and to not just be able to blather
basically what I view to be kind of
brainwashing uh propaganda at Their
audience with nobody having a chance to
say hold on Laura you just said that
only certain kids the only path out for
certain Kids In America is by playing
football are you admitting that there's
systemic racism in this country the
disadvantages kids of color and
especially poor kids of color it sounds
like that's what you're saying to your
audience can we have a discussion about
that as well
that's that's uh not a conversation that
is easy to imagine happening in good
faith on Fox News as you point out you
know in in terms of football
I I believe I correctly understand that
recently football ratings are down to
some degree and there are those on the
political right in the United States
that say it's because of the kneeling
and the woke and you know the stuff that
that they say about it
um do you think that the the brain
injury awareness of the brain injury
component is a factor or is it just the
fragmentation of of audiences as there
are more and more alternatives to
watching live sports that is really what
is to blame or is it hard to know is it
a combination
yeah I don't know and I I think probably
on the margins there are some people
um who were sort of marginal football
fans who have either stopped watching or
maybe cut back their consumption but
it's still the biggest thing in America
and I think the the Hamlin injury
happening at the time it did became such
a huge story because it's a Monday night
game because there's two teams were
really good the ratings were really high
and I just have the feeling as I was
trying to sort of explain like
football's not going to go away because
the government's going to ban it
football's not going to go away because
the woke mob is going to take it away
that's part of the old you know they're
going to take your guns they're going to
take your hamburgers they're going to
take God they're going to get the gas
stoves now is the new one right well
right it's like this idea of if you try
to make any moral Improvement in the
culture we've got to frame it since it's
the enemy of our business interests we
got to frame it as some sort of assault
on your personal Liberty or your
prerogatives or privilege and I think
football is going to diminish in
popularity only at such a time as enough
fans sort of say I think there are other
things that I can consume that are
narratively satisfying to me that don't
cause me to come up against my own sense
of maybe I'm
um rubbernecking uh uh people getting
brain damage and those those wires are
really hard to connect there's a great
book that was written by a former NFL
player years ago and he said I dream of
a day in which football isn't necessary
for the American culture because I
really do think there's a direct line
between kind of the reason that America
is not able to
um put sensible gun control measures
into place the reason that our our sort
of popular culture is a wash and all
these images of violence and our video
games and our you know and football I
think there is like this underlying uh
kind of need to purge our um aggressive
impulses and to kind of consume that
violence that I think is there's a
through line there nobody wants to
connect those dots but it's not a
coincidence that most of the world
watches football that is soccer yeah and
our big sport is um you know is American
football which is just I know people try
to what about with hockey and this that
and the other and it's like okay yeah
any sport can have its dangers but baked
into to football is really big strong
fast guys smashing into one another it's
hidden underneath the helmets in the
uniforms but if those behaviors were
happening outside the context of
football it'd be like oh yeah that's
aggravated battery
is there a way to make football
safer in the sense of you know you read
about well you can have sensors and
helmets which can track cumulative sort
of impact on a player during a game and
then in theory you could pull them out
once some threshold has been reached or
you know all these different ideas on
one level it's like when your brain
changes direction that quickly doesn't
matter how thick the helmet is it's the
brain hitting against the skull to some
degree so like can football actually be
football and be be safer to the players
well it's kind of what you're saying
like when you say football you I think
what you're implying is that there's a
certain amount of risk going back to
like Cormac McCarthy sort of saying like
what is it that we get off on and it's
basically kind of the risk the big hit
we don't want to admit it but there's a
primal sense of these guys are putting
their life on the line and why are they
lionized because they can survive and
play through injury because there's
something real that that I think is
lacking somehow in our lives probably
that's like this Primal atavistic need
to see other people play out a kind of
danger that we're insulated from so I
don't think there's any way around the
fans unacknowledged but powerful lust
for other people to risk on their behalf
I think that's just part of like modern
the the modern condition I do think that
there if there were Financial incentives
uh you know ibid the fox sexual
harassment like only you know a
corporation that makes a lot of money
only changes or a particular demagogue
like Laura Ingram they only change their
tune when they're hit in the pocketbook
the only way the NFL is going to change
their behavior is if fans change their
behavior first and there are plenty of
things that could happen as I tried to
point out like tomorrow weight limits
would be one way since these players are
now
average whatever 270 pounds well what if
they weren't bulking up in the gym and
what if in fact they were you know 200
pounds it's not going to cure it but it
would decrease the amount of impact in
the g-forces the amount those brains are
shaking around putting monitors in
helmets would create a different set of
incentives because suddenly players like
a like a pitcher with a pitch count
suddenly a player would be saying I am
not going to go in with my helmet or I'm
not going to partake in a big hit
because if I do that I'm going to be
pulled out of the game because it's bad
for my brain they don't want the fans
thinking about that again the big goal
of the NFL is to keep the dots
unconnected and they have like a willing
accomplice and fox and the right wing in
this country which essentially says
implicitly or explicitly a buffoon like
Trump says it explicitly like oh yeah
you know football it's like a man's game
now it's sissies they throw the flag all
the time what they're basically saying
is like I'm into violence I know I'm
personally a wimp who tries to get out
of the military and avoid but I'm into I
get off on watching other people be
violent right Steve last thing in the
limited time we have left you mentioned
the fairness Doctrine one of the
difficulties
I think of a reinstatement of the
fairness Doctrine now is that so much of
what we are now are consuming wouldn't
be subject to the fairness Doctrine as
it previously existed because it's on
the internet would you want to see
something specific applied to the
internet when it comes to that or is
that a different question well I I
honestly think that if you have the
power I mean the fairness Doctrine came
into being because in the early 20th
century something happened that the
founders could not have foreseen right
David what they s what happened is mass
media and some you know people in
Congress who were smart said oh my God
there's now this tool that can sway the
hearts and minds of Americans and if it
falls into the wrong hands hands that
are avaricious and only interested in
business or even worse that have a kind
of moral agenda that's inimical to
democracy that would be terrible we
can't let that happen we have to have
some form of Regulation
and people of course on the right and
greedy people freak out about that
because propaganda as you know is very
it sells right Ingram and Tucker and all
those people they are fear mongers for a
living and they make a tremendous amount
of money doing it the fairness Doctrine
said look that is
if we're going to have debates it's
important that media cover and and
participate in debates of of issues that
are publicly important but they have to
do so in a way that includes all
reasonable shade of opinion that's
what's in the Supreme Court decision all
reasonable shade of opinion now I happen
to find a lot of the outright lies and
innuendo and insinuation that that
demagogues traffic in to not be
reasonable shades of opinion but
whatever I'm even cool with having those
propagandists do their thing I just want
somebody like you or me to have equal
time to say Laura when you say that only
certain kids are going to make it
through football what you are admitting
is that America is systemically racist
against people of color and we do not
give them schools and social workers and
Economic Opportunity in their
communities what we give them is like
the the lottery ticket of maybe you can
find your way out not by the content of
your character or your intelligence or
creativity but because you're really
good at throwing a ball and getting
tackled and eventually getting brain
image for my benefit as I cost it a
little you know wimpy person sitting on
my couch getting off on the risk that
you you and that your body assumes so
like that's what I want is for people
like Tucker and Laura Ingram to stop
being such cowards hiding in their
little media silos you know plowing out
their propaganda to fear monger and
brainwash Their audience because I
really have a personal stake in this
people in my life who are important to
me or used to be important to me no
longer think in a reasonable way they've
been scared out of their wits literally
and I think it's I think a lot of
families trumpism is the symptom of this
but I think a lot of American families
would be like you know what we would be
so much healthier and our family systems
would be so much healthier if there
wasn't propaganda allowed on any side
right but especially on the right where
I think it's all about exalting people's
grievance so that people can hide from
their fears and their vulnerabilities
like the stuff that we have to solve and
work out if we're gonna solve climate
change change in inequity and the
violence that besets the culture all
these very real problems we can't do
that if we are allowing a for-profit
business allowing media to become a
for-profit Marketplace it's not it's
supposed to be a Civic institution it's
not supposed to be a for-profit segment
yeah and as a as a topic tangential to
this you mentioned the grievance
component while all at the same time
saying it's the left that has become
about grievance which is just another
instance of the projection that we're
seeing but that's that'll have to be a
topic uh for for another day Steve
Allman the new novel is all the secrets
of the world you can find them on
Twitter at Steve Almond Joy Steve always
great to talk to you
hey uh David it's a delight to talk with
you and the thing about the fairness
Doctrine which we're going to finally
get restored at some point is you can
you would be fabulous I want to see a
David packman sitting in the same DS
with one of these propagandists and
saying look I do not consent to the
false narrative that you're weaving like
that's my dream
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
so the brains of Maga seem to be
breaking over this new Story related to
some classified documents that were left
behind at an office of then Vice
President Joe Biden now I have made
every effort and it hasn't been very
difficult to be consistent about this
story uh Donald Trump should have and is
it being investigated for his handling
of classified documents including taking
a whole bunch of them to his house and
then lying about where they are and then
avoiding returning them and all these
different things and Joe Biden should
likewise be investigated now the
circumstances of course are completely
different we're talking about a couple
about a dozen or so documents with Joe
Biden and we're talking about what
hundreds or more with Trump we're
talking about something with Joe Biden
where when his lawyers found out they
immediately notified the National
Archives it was the opposite with Trump
there is no evidence whatsoever that Joe
Biden asked or was even involved in
these documents remaining where they
were whereas there is wide spread
testimony that Donald Trump specifically
said take these documents down to
Mar-A-Lago there are no similarities but
I am consistent investigate everyone and
everything and see where it shakes out
right Wingers brains seem to have been
scrambled by this here is Ronnie Jackson
who says he believes these documents
were found as part of a conspiracy by
democrats to push Biden out before 2024.
and it could be happening here Jin is
that I've been saying for a long time
that the Democrats are going to have to
figure out a way to get rid of Joe Biden
they don't want this man to run for
president again he's a recipe for
disaster in the next presidential
election so I think you know a lot of
people thought it would be his cognitive
issue you know I thought so as well but
I thought well maybe they won't go down
there because that's admitting to fate
that they put this cognitively
incompetent man in a position like the
president of the United States I said
all along I thought maybe they would let
the hunter Biden thing blow up a little
bit but maybe this is what they're doing
maybe this is the first shot that
they're going to fire to try to get him
in a position where he ultimately has to
resign or at least has to decide that
he's not going to run again now the
reason this is very stupid is of course
number one there's no evidence of that
but number two it doesn't really make
sense because as I talked about at the
top of the show why is Joe Biden a
disaster in the sense that in polling
against Trump Biden is mostly winning
for 2024. unemployment is the lowest
it's been in 50 years inflation has come
down six months in a row wages are up
the idea that it's obviously a disaster
for Biden to run isn't borne out by the
facts now here's Alina Haba Trump's
lawyer who says what about her being
special prosecutor on Biden's boxes of
course there are no boxes we're talking
about 12 12 documents Elena do you think
this completely exonerates Trump from
the the Merrick Garland documents Witch
Hunt
I think so and I think that more
importantly we should oh by the way on
this exoneration thing they don't seem
to get that just because someone else is
being investigated for something it
doesn't mean you're exonerated it's sort
I use this analogy yesterday and it's so
simple but it's so so uh emblematic of
this
if I am accused of murder
and then someone else is accused of
murder I don't get to say I'm exonerated
because someone else is now being
investigated for murder that's the
argument they're making here and it's a
very silly argument point out one thing
very important Donald Trump was the
sitting president of the United States
had the ability to declassify the
presidential records act applied to him
Biden doesn't have that excuse he was
the vice president yes now he's the
sitting president but these are
documents that we're taking during the
Obama Administration they are in places
that are not secure he was a PR he was
not a president at the time he had no
right to them I saw an article today I
believe and and it said that he had the
presidential records incorrect he was a
vice president he's not afforded those
protections and he doesn't have the
ability to do so so I think that this
does help president Trump quite honestly
I don't think president Trump needed
help because I don't think he did
anything wrong we now by the way I I
know Alina Hab is an attorney
the research she says the presidential
records act doesn't apply to the vice
president I I believe it does the
research I've been able to find says
that the presidential records Act of
1978 governs both the President and Vice
President
maybe I'm misunderstanding that I don't
know we're cooperating as you know and
and that matter is underway but they
weren't cooperating they have to show
that they're going to treat everybody
the same and I would like to personally
offer to be the special prosecutor on
Biden's boxes because yeah there are no
boxes because we're talking about 12
documents that were immediately uh told
the National Archives were immediately
notified by Biden's lawyers lastly
here's Claudia Tenney saying that
Biden's the biggest liar in American
politics she may be forgetting about a
guy who told like 14 000 lies during his
presidency look I give her credit
because to be the press secretary and
have to lie for the biggest liar in
modern politics is quite an
extraordinary obligation and job I give
her I mean what's she gonna say he may
not even know where they are but look we
look I give her credit because so that's
a republican congresswoman Claudia
Tenney now the story is Biden is the
biggest liar that is out there their
brain remains have been scrambled and
it's very very easy to be consistent on
this we say oh anytime there's a
question about documents and presidents
or former presidents or vice presidents
investigate it and then go where the
facts take you what we know about the
facts of the Biden situation and the
Trump situation
are so dramatically different that it's
laughable to suggest there is even any
similarity but again investigate
everyone Hunter Biden investigate under
Biden it's just not an issue for the
House of Representatives since it has
nothing whatsoever to do with politics
or the Biden Administration but if
Hunter Biden broke some law
with law enforcement investigate them
it's a we this isn't about protecting
Democrats it's about having some kind of
consistent standard about what we
consider to be wrongdoing hey this may
or may not surprise some of you yet
another Republican has been found guilty
of voter fraud and you know I saw the
headline former New York election
official pleads guilty to ballot fraud
I knew it was going to be a republican
but I figured I should look at the
article just to make sure and of course
it was Jason Schofield a republican who
recently resigned from the Rensselaer
County Board of Elections in New York
admitted he applied for absentee ballots
using other people's per other voters
personal information
he pleaded guilty yesterday to applying
for absentee ballots in the names of
others he's from Troy New York he
resigned last month and he admits back
in 2021 he unlawfully used the names and
birth dates of Voters in connection with
12 absentee ballot applications that he
electronically submitted to the New York
State utter absentee ballot application
request portal portal he's 43 years old
he admits he falsely certified that he
was those 12 different people he was
originally arraigned in September his
attorney said showfield maintained his
innocence in the 12-count indictment
he's scheduled to be sentenced May 12th
he faces up to five years in prison a
fine of a quarter million dollars and
supervised release of up to three years
for each count the really important
takeaway here continues to be individual
voter fraud of this kind is very very
rare in the United States there's a
study by the Brennan Center for justice
voter fraud occurs at a rate of less
than
0.0003 percent
that's like one case of fraud for every
30 million votes that are cast and other
Studies have found the same however
when we do find stories of individual
voter fraud aside from being really rare
they are mostly Republicans and it's a
really terrible way to try to win
elections and the reason is that the
scale is so small and the risk's so big
voter fraud of this kind often involves
one or a few people trying to sway the
outcome of an election at least in
theory and even if they get away with
their small-scale voter fraud the impact
on the overall results would rarely be
significant now if it's a really really
really tiny election you know a town of
800 people in which only a fraction are
adults and only a fraction vote and it
could come down to five votes and you do
this with 12 ballots maybe you can swing
an election insanely unlikely and the
risk is too high they love to say we
have no way of catching these people we
seem to catch plenty of them and they
almost exclusively are Republicans who
are either trying to test the system or
are saying it's actually Democrats who
are doing it so another case relatively
rare
but it just so happens that it's yet
another Republican sentencing in May
we'll see if they throw the book at him
which would mean five years and that
would be pretty interesting to see I
must say we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P if you have
something to say to me
you can say it to my voicemail line even
if it's 3am when you get the idea
um here is the Eggman he is not buying
my entire I'm Argentinian thing at least
not in terms of me just being a white
guy take a listen to this
hi Dave um I know you're Argentinian and
you guys won the FIFA thing you know
whatever right um congratulations to you
the Eggman is not big on Sports and he
will admit that to you David you're a
New York white guy okay I'm gonna have
to agree with Donald Trump over you yeah
in the pronunciation of his soccer draw
a soccer freaking sock draw okay you put
your socks in the drawer and you close
it what's the problem
shallow brother
sock drawer
drawers yeah listen uh I didn't grow up
in New York so I have not adopted any of
these New York accent elements uh I
believe that my accent is What's called
the southern western New England accent
and sock draw doesn't make any sense to
me it's it's a sock drawer it's a drawer
it's a a number of drawers many drawers
draw it doesn't make any sense uh but in
any case
it the story Trump told about the sock
draw was very much untrue okay on the
bonus show today what the hell happened
with the FAA and all flights being
temporarily grounded and how much blame
does Secretary of Transportation Pete
boot Edge
bootage Edge how much blame does uh
secretary Pete
deserve Fox News thinks it's a lot and
we'll talk about it the Biden
Administration is going to be selecting
the first 10 drugs for which it will
negotiate prices within the Medicare
program by September
what drugs might those be we will
discuss and what will the impact on
pricing be we will also talk about that
and lastly House Republicans they want
people back to work they want everybody
back in the office House Republicans are
introducing a bill to return all federal
employees to the office I have a number
of friends who are federal employees and
uh they aren't thrilled and I understand
why many of their jobs really don't need
to be done in an office quite frankly uh
we will talk about it on the bonus show
when producer Patton joins me from sunny
Florida you can get instant access to
the bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money please everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad yeah well I don't know about that
but you can sign up at joinpakman.com
and you can use the coupon code 24
starts now to save big you get 100 of
the benefits but at half the price hard
to beat that I will see you on the bonus
Drive
foreign